That. I'm a fan of that one. I'm not a fan of investment.
What I have a question about is,
is there a some buddy in charge of what,
what's permissible and what's not according to a certain code of conduct and do
they have a political agenda? So in other words,
so if I put out something that has profanity or maybe I'll stand up clip where I
want to get people in. It's,
it's a clip that is offensive to said person touched possibilities. Yeah.
They can go, Nope. We're stopping them from doing that. See with the,
with the dudes with their shirts off flex and shit,
when they're trying to get clients, that's fine. And they can promote,
reach other people outside their followers is what it should be. Yeah.
But if you have 100,000 followers,
it should reach all 100,000 then that's what's crazy to me. Yeah.
They're going to lose everybody. There's going to be a new Instagram.
If they started doing that shit and it gets out of hand, people just leave.
Well there's, you know, it's shadow banning is right. No,
there's a concept of shadow banning and I don't know if this is Jamie would be
able to speak to this better than me.
Is that ever been proved that they actually do shadow banned people?
What's that? Or is that it's they
[inaudible] is that if you say we're on Twitter and maybe you were conservative
and you said a lot of rude things about liberals that maybe they would decide
that although it doesn't violate the terms of service, what you do is, uh,
makes them uncomfortable.
They make a moral judgment and they decide to limit your engagement talking
about, yeah, this is somehow possible. This is possible.
But is that like a hater?
It's all in what you're saying with the paying of of post two.
It happens similarly there too. If you were an account that never paid.
Yeah. And once you pay, once you give him five bucks, you're,
you're like flag now as an account that will pay and change your engagement.
Twitter, it's Twitter. You don't across the board. Yeah.
You can pay on Twitter too. How do you pay on Twitter? Do you pay on Twitter?
You don't have to, but there's an option. You can pay promoted tweets.
It's a promoted tweet.
The top trending topic for the last year or two is a paid,
it says paid or promoted. Really? Yeah.
You just had to go into it because they get money now.
That's how they're called. Who's been banned from Twitter? A lot of people, man,
he fucking, the most famous Benjamin Benjamin's been banned from Twitter.
He has and more conservatives are conservatives, but liberals I've been to,
there's liberals that have put out death threats. They'd been banned,
but in general they should be lopsided.
I don't know. That's a good question. We should find out what is the,
what is the press should be banned being banned. That's a good question too.
Is it
[inaudible] the violate their terms of service and definitely if you incite
violence, that's definitely a no,
no racial slurs or no-no racist.
You can call someone a fuckhead. You can call someone a fuck head,
but you can't call them like a Guinea fuck head. There's like,
there's certain things you can say and certain things you can't say,
but it's a lot of it's, yeah. But then some of it's pretty black and white.
Like if you're like, man, I want to go socia blow up that fucking school.
Fuck those kids. Of course, the racist stuff. Yeah. Yes. All of that.
I think you gotta regulate the hate too.
If it's just bullying and shit like that. We just ban them. Well, it's like,
here's the question and this is who gets to decide who,
what's hateful and what's not.
And then the problem is they keep pushing it further and further and further and
then even just insults or hateful, even even like this guy is a dumb ass.
Yeah. That's hateful. Saying someone's a dumb ass. It's hateful.
I mean they're going to, there's only so far you can,
you could keep going down that road. Right?
You want to make sure that you have free expression and you don't get free
expression.
If you ban people from saying things that just don't seem that bad to me.
Well, I mean, Alex Jones, you think a Hispanic, I'd like to see what he says.
Sandy hook stuff. Sandy. But see, but here's the thing. Getting sued for that.
Anyway, here's the thing. Yeah. He was already getting sued for that.
Like what did he say that got him?
I think something happened that he did had nothing to do with even what he said.
He confronted them at some events. Right?
And he was yelling in the back and that happened after he confronted people in
Congress. Well, he's got a,
Alex Jones has a regular on a former CIA officer,
dr Steve [inaudible]. He has him on like once every six months.
That's where he got the Sandy hook information was from him.
That dude is on video as a CIA guy know about Sandy hook.
The fuck would he know that's a dumbest fucking thing that Alex Jones has ever
done. It's also a moral, and there's parents who said, fuck dr Steve,
that guy, fuck whatever. If he said it didn't fuck [inaudible] yeah.
You have to always wonder and you would you, I mean,
I'm not making any accusations,
but you'd have to always wonder when you hear a story like that,
why would someone say something so ridiculous?
And why would someone try to convince someone like Alex Jones of something so
ridiculous? And I think there'd be two reasons. One to discredit Jones.
If you could talk him into repeating what you said,
if you think he's willing to do, that's interesting.
You can easily discredit him and it would be a really good way to do it.
Like the best way to do it. Okay. Do you know what I'm saying?
Whether he's right or wrong, whether he's right or wrong,
doctors deep paternics said it several times on the show, so,
but he's not Alex for Alex to believe him. No, it started like this,
that crazy Eddie,
he's hearing it from a guy who was in the CIA started like this.
It started out crazy for him to believe in a guy from, you know,
he may or may not be right, but it started with Alex actually saying, uh, uh,
he said, unfortunately he goes something to the effect of I saw it,
it was very sad. And then,
but unfortunately I've seen a lot of soap operas and I've seen a lot of and,
and,
and I know an actor when I see one and that's where it started with him and he's
being, you know, he's being sued by Connecticut. He's in trouble,
be a good acting coach.
But remember he knows an act [inaudible] in court and they said, what the fuck?
Basically, what the fuck are you doing? He goes, listen,
I say a lot of things just for entertaining of course.
Like it's just for the during, is that his trial with his wife?
He did admit, he's like, uh, I don't believe it.
A lot of that I just say he's got a business. Yeah,
well that's the thing about all a lot of nutrition people,
a lot of these people is you make money. You make money in this,
in this business. And whether, whatever it is,
whether it's being a political pundit,
whether it's being attainment or an exercise guy, you make money having answers.
If you're somebody who's more scientific and says, I dunno, it depends.
Maybe you're not going to make money. When you say bone broth cures cancer,
you're going to sell books. When you say, uh,
my plant based diet is proven to do blah, blah, blah, whatever,
you're going to make money. If you say, I'm going to,
I'll help you lose weight and keep it off in four month, take my money,
you're not going to say, Hey, I'm a nutritionist guy.
It's going to take you two years. We're going to try to change life.
You're gonna have bounce backs. You're gonna have plateaus and being realistic.
Yeah, nobody's going to buy that shit.
This your Dawn guy has got a movement man. So, but with, uh,
with Alex Jones, is he banned for life or I don't know how a business, well,
I mean, he still has his website.
He's got a big lawsuit he's got gotta worry about,
but it shows they got rid of his show happen all the farmers. And shit. No,
the only thing that happened is they pulled him off of YouTube and they pulled
him off at Twitter and Facebook to an iTunes and he's got a major lawsuit with
law firm that doesn't compromise. There's tears. There's two guys,
there's two guys that are being sued over that. Uh,
Alex Jones and a guy name a Wolf gang.
Helbig he's also, he's also being sued. That guy,
his job was to prepare schools for, uh, school shootings.
So he came out and he started saying that too. So he's, he's breaking apart.
He started saying that San Diego, he's getting,
he's getting sued along with Alex Jones. Oh my God. Well,
but they didn't show up for when you went to court. They'd never showed up.
So they dropped the case. What about one thing about the law law?
It's kind of weird now that they're, they have,
why would Sandy hook be fake? Let's not talk about this stuff. Oh, I don't know.
I find it fascinating. Well, like why in the world would it be fake though be,
I know you get wrapped up like what's the conspiracy?
Zero zero thoughts that that is fake.
But I do have thoughts on why someone would try to get other people to say it's
fake. And this if there's any,
if there's anything that's ever going to convince you that conspiracy theories
are stupid, it's making up a fake conspiracy,
an easily provable fake conspiracy about a real tragedy. That's a nice,
simple psychological way to discredit people.
If I thought you were a dumb ass but you had a big voice,
I might talk you into saying some shit about something that's not real and have
you convinced it's real. So you spout it out, you look like a moron, right?
And that discredits everything else you said.
And you have to be really careful with a lot of these stories.
There's a lot of these,
these conspiracy theories that literally start out a joke.
They start out in four Chan and a lot of these chat rooms as trolls and then
before you know it,
it becomes a real thing that's said over and over and so said over and over
again and then morons get ahold of. But [inaudible] true, right?
Like he's a smart, we can all agree he's a, I don't agree.
What do you mean you don't think he's, I don't know to do what he's doing.
Listen, I don't ever talk about stuff [inaudible] no, no.
You would not say he's a dumb person. I don't know. I, I can't speak.
Pretty articulate. Yeah. He's not stupid. Like I'm very,
very sad that he said that Sandy hook isn't real. I fuck with him.
But I always enjoy being around that guy.
You would say he's articulate smart guy. Right? He's a fun guy too. Yeah.
So I'm just saying for him to,
it's not like you can just honey Dick and be like, dude, Sandy hook.
Like it would have to be something. He loves conspiracies, man. You know,
he really does.
And this is the problem with someone who likes hunts out conspiracies.
You're going to love them, you're going to, you're gonna look for them.
[inaudible] numerology and the Bible. You can find any pattern.
This is the problem is when you have a vested interest in them being real,
when it's your business, because there are a lot of them that are real.
So the problem is if you have a vested interest in them being real and you
exclude information that would point to them not being real and you use
confirmation bias and you fuck up and then you try to convince other people that
you're correct. This is something that people will fall.
[inaudible] I'd love to hear you on. You're super quiet about all this,
but if you're a conspiracy theory, which ones have been proven correct?
That many, right? There's plenty. Absolutely. There's big ones like Enron,
you know, there's big ones. There's big ones. You know, there's uh,
many documentaries and books have been written on the, the Enron conspiracy.
These guys got together and they figured out how to make a kajillion dollars and
fuck people over. And it was, it was,
it was breaking the law and they knew it was breaking law.
They conspire to do it and by names and phone so you can take, take them.
There's wise people to think the 2008 hires, housing crisis, that that was the,
that was all on purpose. These guys built this bubble up and it's proven though.
It's not proven. It's not proven. The housing bubble was,
there've been great books written on it by Michael Lewis's book, the big shorts,
a good book on it. Yeah. But you know, there's been a lot of research on that.
Too many bank. Is there any proven ones but it all depends.
Bread and despise again? No, no, no, no, no. And he knows his shit.
It all depends on how much circumstantial evidence, uh,
makes you throw up some red flags.
Like some people they just don't see the red flags and some people,
their red flags go up right away. So it all depends.
Like when you say is there any proof? Well, um, you don't need,
uh, I mean at,
at a certain point when you have circumstantial evidence,
at a certain point it adds up. You know, you know,
if I'm one of case, pretty suspect JFK suspect is fucked.
There's no look Jeff K's a perfect example, right? Yeah.
There's no actual proof of the conspiracy that there was a, you know,
multiple shooters or the CIA and the mob. There's no actual proof,
but there's a lot of circumstantial evidence. Right. So it all depends on,
it all depends on how much circumstantial evidence do you need for any
particular conspiracy theory where you go, Oh shit,
there's enough circumstantial evidence. Like if there was a murder, right,
and you were being accused and only one person said, you know,
I saw Brendan like four blocks away from the restaurant where his friend was
killed. If just that one person saw it.
That's one piece of circumstantial evidence. That's not enough to convict you.
But if a hundred people said they saw you two blocks away in the parking lot,
none of it alone, none of it standing alone will put you in jail.
But at a certain point, enough circumstantial evidence,
we'll put dudes in jail or if enough people tell the same story about you,
like with Cosby, it was the same story over and over.
It's like not all these women can't be,
they're all telling the exact same story about the same MOU. Well not only that,
Cosby had gone to court and had a lawsuit sealed and paid her woman off.
That's right. I get it. It already had been to the deposition so that, yeah,
so this was a part of the whole thing was that he had to come out and uh,
you know, the, the had to defend that in his most recent trial.
Bill Clinton too. I just got done watching those Monica Lewinsky tapes. Yeah.
Bill Quinn was a freak. Oh yeah. Dude.
Do you know that the only problem with like being but like it sounded like Alex
Jones who makes a lot of money off his conspiracies and things is that if once
he says something, I know a pretty good fan of his Alex. And um,
what the problem is once you say something and you have that big of a following,
right? So let's just say you float out of conspiracy,
but then you look at evidence and you start to realize,
maybe I overstepped my boss, we all say things we wish we hadn't,
or we all say things.
But now you've got a whole movement behind what you said now to try to pull back
with turn that 25% of the whoever it is against you.
And that can be a liability too.
So one of the things about being a public figure is you can say something and if
you're selling product and selling your show on, you better be all in.
You better stay all that.
So you become a prisoner to your own kind of first impulse or your own first
sort of like, no matter how Atlanta, especially if he's also an entertainer,
it's also this rush to say you'd know something when you don't know it is a rush
to say there's a rush to say, we absolutely know this happened.
We absolutely know that happened cause
[inaudible] to get it from somewhere. He has his sources.
What gets probably got information on on the, on these, you know,
these tragic events or something like that or you don't think there'll be,
I just looking at Brandon, listen, I think he has some people in trouble. No,
I'm not. Don't take your bait, Eddie. He's floating the fucking huge worm out.
[inaudible]
come on this show and try not to talk about conspiracy theories,
but I always get sucked back into them. I always get sucked back to,
I'm not, but look, look, he's there. Legit question. I don't know.
You're asking super crazy legit questions.